monsieur manigold merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors jean
castex l'a dit ce matin nous allons très
fortement accompagner les restaurateurs
jusque là vous êtes vous senti soutenu
par l'exécutif ont déjà souligné qu'il
ya de bonnes nouvelles on le sait bruno
le maire est à nos côtés il est absent
aujourd'hui de cette conférence de
presse mais on peut déjà souligné les
avancées que nous avons eues les 1 %
obtenus à partir du 1er décembre ce
chiffre d'affaires c'est une avancée ça
va donner
soyons clair un bol d'air à 80% des 220
milles restaurateurs français et on ne
peut que se féliciter de cette bonne
nouvelle
la deuxième bonne nouvelle c'est que le
premier ministre a annoncé que 2010
serait l'année de la gastronomie
française
c'est bien c'est une bonne nouvelle ça
veut dire que 2020 on a des perspectives
un peu plus positive que celle de 2020
je le rappelle simplement mais il le
sait certainement que la france et le
repas des français est classé au
patrimoine mondial au patrimoine
immatériel mondial de l'unesco depuis
2010 donc c'est bien que le chef du
gouvernement la chef de la majorité
prennent conscience de cette situation
en revanche on l'observé et de nombreux
restaurateurs le disent ce qu'ils
souhaitent aujourd'hui c'est de pouvoir
travailler
la dignité est en recul on pense
également à l'ensemble de l'écosystème à
nos agriculteurs
on n'entend pas trop le ministre de
l'agriculture en parler mais nous on en
parle parce que si elle fait partie de
notre écosystème et que sans nos
agriculteurs français sont nos vignerons
sans tout ce savoir
sans cette exception gastronomique qui
fait rayonner la france est bien sans
ses artisans
père mère et bien on serait pas grand
chose donc on a une vraie pensée pour
nos amis vignerons ils ont été un peu
oubliée agriculteurs on le rappelle et
on espère que
le gouvernement avant sera également sur
cette question de notre écosystème que
soient les agriculteurs et les vignerons
je vous le disais tout à l'heure mais
également toute la chaîne de
distribution qui aujourd'hui est en
péril il a annoncé qu'il y avait des
mesures qui mise en place pour tous cet
écosystème ceux qui ne sont pas fermées
administrativement mais qui dépendent
exclusivement des des établissements
fermés comme les nôtres on espère que
que ces établissements vont être
soutenus
après la colère on l'entend il faut
qu'on puisse trouver un moment où sortie
de cette crise absolue parce que on le
voit bien des manifestations sont
organisées un peu partout en france
marseille demain
il est le 15 le 15 décembre à lyon je
sais que bono le maire quitte à les
gouttes de ce qu'ils écoutent
c'est un vrai passionné de la
gastronomie et du terroir français
il était mise et l'agriculture donc il a
cette sensibilité du terroir et du
terroir div en france il faut plus
président de la république amplifie
derrière les arbitrages concernant
madame elisabeth bornes
la ministre du travail il faut qu'elle
nous accompagne sur les salariés
vous rendez vous compte nous avons
toujours ces fameux 10% de congés payés
qui reste à charge sur les entreprises
cela représente des sommes absolument
astronomiques
le ministre du travail ne peut pas faire
l'impasse sur une discussion qui dure
maintenant depuis huit mois plus de 8 -
d'ailleurs il faut que qu'on puisse
donner une vraie réponse
elle a promis une réponse semaine
prochaine nous les attendons je dirais
de pied ferme avec le sourire aussi et
avec une forme de joie à cl si elle si
elle prend en charge parce que c'est une
aberration fait rentrer pas de chiffre
d'affaires et on doit quand même
provisionné ces 10% de congés payés sur
notre masse salariale
on ne peut rien on veut bien lutter
contre la propagation du virus
mais l'état doit être dans le quoi qu'il
en coûte quelques couacs il en
connaissait aussi ça et cette
réouverture peut-être le 20 janvier est
ce que c'est pas une lueur d'espoir pour
vous il a pas dix ouvertures 20 janvier
il est dit qu'il referait le point mi
janvier
il ya une ambiguïté là dessus c'est une
étape on avait demandé de la visibilité
bombes allaient nous en a donné on ne
peut pas on peut pas s'en plaindre
ça fait deux mois ça c'est trop long
c'est là on passe les périodes de fêtes
c'est les périodes où on fait le plus de
chiffre d'affaires setc les événements
familiaux les retrouvailles les
événements d'entreprise pas tous ces
événements où les gens venaient dans nos
établissements pour les cp et mais à
tous ces petits hôtels la du mois de
novembre et décembre qui sont quand même
les plus gros mois notamment en ile de
france
eh bien il vient on n'y a pas on n'y a
pas accès c'est un nouveau coup dur pour
notre profession
ce qu'on demande c'est de travailler on
est des travailleurs on se lève à 5
heures du matin on se couche bien
souvent à 1h 2h du matin on est des
besogneux mais là on assez de france qui
travaille et cette france qui est à
l'arrêt et qui demande à travailler luis
espèce de contradiction absolue
monsieur magnet gun merci d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes co fondateur et porte parole
du collectif
restons ouverts martias beau